voir et oui c'est bien michel rocard qui
est ce soir notre invité michel rocard
l'homme politique le plus populaire de
france et de loin qui est aussi le plus
avare d'apparitions à la télévision
michel rocard qui a été candidat à la
présidence de la république en 1969 qui
a essayé mais en vain de l'être aussi en
1981 et qui depuis que son parti le
parti socialiste est au pouvoir a
pratiquement refusé de parler politique
mérite et vous monsieur le ministre
votre première place dans les sondages
rivarol disait vous le savez le silence
n'a jamais trahi personne
on saura dans un peu plus d'une heure si
la parole elle peut trahir celui qui la
prend et je dirais celui qui est obligé
de la prendre car j'ai actuellement j'ai
là sous les yeux un sondage de l'ifrap
l'institut français de recherche psycho
sociologiques qui est consacré à votre
image
eh bien les français trouvent que vous
avez le bon look comme on dit
aujourd'hui il trouve que vous êtes
compétent mais ils vous reprochent de ne
pas être assez présent dans la vie
politique
alors certes vous avez remporté un
certain nombre de succès comme ministre
de l'agriculture vous avez même réussi
l'autre semaine à faire voter et
applaudir votre projet sur les relations
entre l'état et l'enseignement agricole
privé mais les français vous le savez
attendent autre chose de vous ils
attendent de savoir si vous approuvez
l'action du gouvernement de monsieur
fabius
vous êtes toujours membre de ce
gouvernement mais à trois reprises si je
suis bien informé
au cours de ces dernières semaines vous
avez mis votre démission dans la balance
alors que comptez-vous faire de la
confiance massive
je dirais même écrasante que vous
accorde les français ils ont le droit de
savoir le droit de connaître votre
pensée politique et vos projets le droit
d'être informés sur le sens de votre le
sens véritable de votre socialisme
alors alain duhamel alain duhamel albert
du roy et jean boissonnat vont vous
aider à préciser votre pensée dans sur
tous ces points et aussi bien sûr sur
l'actualité chaude
du moment je pense notamment à la
nouvelle calédonie mais auparavant une
première question de ce bp jean-louis le
scène michel rocard bonsoir il ici svp
beaucoup de questions qui concernent ce
soir votre secteur ministériel
l'agriculture beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui s'applique à vous
interroger sur une entreprise
particulièrement en difficulté dans
votre circonscription ltt à conflans
sainte honorine
nous y reviendrons car les premières
fiches sont en nombre plus politique
par exemple un directeur commercial de
marseille vous demande si vous êtes
encore vraiment solidaire d'un
gouvernement qui collectionne les échecs
et qu'il ne satisfait que 25% des
français et une infirmière de
sartrouville vous pose cette question
accepteriez vous monsieur le ministre de
vous présenter ce soir comme le chef de
file de l'actuelle majorité
[Musique]
avant de répondre à cette question je
veux tout de même relevé un propos que
vous avez tenus françois henri de virieu
sur l'hypothèse de ma démission et je
voudrais dire avec la plus grande
fermeté que la politique n'est pas un
spectacle que je ne suis pas venu ce
soir pour faire des coups je suis venu
ce soir parce que la france est inquiète
parce que les français ont peur pour
leur emploi pour leur sécurité pour
l'avenir de leurs enfants se rendent mal
compte de la quel point tout cela dépend
du monde international autour de nous et
dans cette situation là le débat
politique se crisper les questions
tendrait à le montrer aux jeux mon
propos ce soir est de montrer que
l'avenir est à portée de main si nous
avons le prendre ensemble mais que le
seul danger qui guette la france c'est
celui d intolérance des sectarismes et
des fanatismes
alors mes rapports avec une heure pour
faire votre démonstration oui mais il ya
eu tellement de choses dit que je
voulais que les choses soient
parfaitement claires alors la question
à la seconde question il n'y a pas de
sens
je dirais simplement ce qui concerne la
première question le mot de solidarité
s'applique à toute une espérance s'il a
un sens c'est
un sens qui concerne l'ensemble des
électeurs qui ont porté cet espoir et je
crois qu'il faut dire de la situation et
la france aujourd'hui deux choses à
titre principal
la première c'est que la crise
économique est plus profonde et plus
durable que toutes les forces politiques
y compris la gauche mais pas seulement
la gauche ne l'avait dit pour monsieur
giscard d'estaing la crise économique
était conjoncturelle la sortie du tunnel
est pour bientôt la reprise et pour
l'automne toutes ses phrases sont datés
1975 1976 mais nous aussi nous avions
sous-estimé la crise ayant sous-estimé
la crise nous ne sommes plus cru sur
parole
c'est la principale difficulté l'arbre à
cela bien sûr est l'acte ou tel discours
peut créer des difficultés et je ne
connais pas dans aucun gouvernement de
la planète à aucun moment de l'histoire
un mini ce qui peut se dire j'ai d'un
bout à l'autre du début jusqu'à la fin
était d'accord avec tout ça n'existe pas
on est solidaires d'un vaste mouvement
collectif est au fond la solidarité ça
ne compte que quand elle fait mal le
reste du temps c'est facile c'est une
des formes de la discipline sans lequel
ya pas d'efficacité
jean-louis le cèdre est ce que vous nous
rappeler la question la deuxième
question accepteriez vous de vous
présenter comme un des chefs de file de
l'actuelle majorité
c'est le scène on ne s'autoproclame toit
très bien je crois que c'est clair
monsieur mise quand même je vous posais
une question un petit peu personnel vous
avez lu les journaux ces derniers jours
on parle de votre résurrection par le
venue ce soir
est ce que au fond les gens attendent
quelque chose de vous est ce que ça ne
vous fait pas peur à ce que vous n'avez
pas peur de décevoir les gens qui ce
soir nous regarde ce qui l'attend je la
trouve doit d'abord que si l' on
travaillerait en politique avec la peur
il ferait du bien mauvais trafic je
crois ensuite n'avoir pas à m'expliquer
sur le fait de mettre longtemps tue qui
inquiète et français sur la vie de notre
pays c'est au fond qu'on y bavarde
peut-être un peu trop et je crois que
pour un homme chargé de fonction
publique le droit de parler se mérite
par l'efficacité dans l'action je vais
passer longtemps dans l'opposition on y
exerce exclusivement le magistère ou le
ministère de la parole c'est sa fonction
c'est difficile je n'étais pas si sûr de
pouvoir être efficace dans l'action
excusez moi il le met bien fallu
m'expliquer avec mon métier je pense
l'avoir fait propre très bien et bien
écoutez alain duhamel va venir vous
interrogez maintenant pour
un quart d'heure alors alain duhamel
bonsoir monsieur rocard bonsoir je
verrai est ce que votre dernier livre
est en 1979 s'appelait parler vrai est
ce que quand on est ministre on peut
parler vrai et bien tenté d'en faire la
démonstration ce soir pourquoi
non mais est ce que vous vous pensé
quand on est ministre on peut parler
vrai il est probable qu'on ne peut pas
tout dire encore que j'en doute mais on
peut sûrement parler vrai bon je me suis
même pas sûr qu'il ya des inconvénients
à ça alors virieu faisait allusion dans
sa présentation à ce qui était rappelé
encore ce soir à la une du monde est un
journal sérieux c'est à dire le fait que
vous auriez à trois reprises ces
dernières semaines me votre
participation ministérielle dans la
balance non pas pour des raisons de
démarquage politique mais pour des
raisons de dissentiment sur des
questions dont vous êtes responsable est
ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est
faux comme dans beaucoup de choses c'est
largement faux mais il n'y a pas tout à
fait de fumée sans feu
la vraie question chacun la comprendra
vite les ministres ne sont pas tous
chargés de la même chose il ya une
division du travail nous avons des
tâches
nous avons besoin de moyens pour remplir
ses tâches et on peut c'est arrivé à
tous mes collègues
ça nous est comme se trouvait à certains
moments devant certains problèmes d'une
gravité suffisante pour se dire si y'a
pas un accord interministériel notamment
financiers sur cela je ne passerai pas
je ne tiendrais pas m'est arrivé de le
faire remarquer j'ai eu gain de cause
dans les trois quarts mais je vais vous
avez mis votre présence dans la balance
les ralentissements mais on est tous là
et j'ai eu à le faire en dix ans je ne
tiendrais pas nous amener tout cela dans
tous les gouvernements de la planète à
chaque moment n'importe qui qui est
chargé de quoi que ce soit se dit est-ce
que j'ai les moyens de faire ce qu'on me
demande ou pas alors que danseuse et
qu'une banalité excusez moi mais il est
vrai ce qui est moins banal
ce qui est moins banal c'est que dans le
métier que je fais présentement j'ai
pour mission de faire face à une grave
crise de l'agriculture française et
européenne dans une situation de rareté
budgétaire extrême c'est un travail
impossible
et il est vrai que j'ai rencontré des
difficultés plus lourdes peut-être qu'en
d'autres temps tell dem école c'est vrai
bien est ce que vous vous détendez
puisqu'on en est là je voudrais
continuer à ajouter quelque chose dans
le la formulation des questions tout à
l'heure et dans ce que disait monsieur
dire yeux on avait l'impression que
l'agriculture c'était marginal
parce que ça viendrait peut-être avec
jean boissonnat qui s'y colle ou laissé
mourir ses parties moi je tiens à vous
dire d'entrée de jeu alors river jambes
parce que j'ai non non je vous dis ça
c'est moi si vous voulez non mais oui
mais je voudrais question je voudrais
simplement alors moi ce que je voudrais
c'est à kamel évidemment mais ce que je
souhaite c'est pendant ce quart d'heure
j'assemble de questions politiques vous
posez ensuite jean bosco droit mais ces
groupes qui avait introduit la manière
dont je faisais mon métier
alors je voudrais dire ici très
nettement que l'agriculture française
c'est une des partie de l'avenir de la
france
nos chances la france de demain elle
doit beaucoup à nous notre puissance
technique à notre capacité exportatrice
à notre capacité en recherche
scientifique d'être toujours à la pointe
est ce que les français savent peu c'est
que dans cette puissance exportatrice
dans ce qui fait la france de demain il
ya probablement un le nucléaire civil de
le sucre tout ce qui y touche 3 la fusée
ariane 4 le blé tout ce qui touche 5
certaines filières électronique ou
l'aéronautique lourde 6 nos techniques
de distribution commerciale moderne
voilà comment s'interpénètrent les
chances d'avenir de la france et j'ai ma
part de responsabilité là dedans et
j'entends bien que cela ne soit pas
retenue pour marginal bien alors ça fait
exactement quatre ans que vous n'avez
pas parler de politique
vous avez parlé de vos responsabilités
mais vous n'avez pas fait vous n'avez
pas voulu faire des missions politiques
et donc qu'en quatre ans un certain
nombre de questions vous le comprendrez
qu'il se sont accumulés et qui intéresse
peut être aussi les français alors
d'abord aux gens pour ie alors d'abord
première question on le disait tout à
l'heure
l'image du gouvernement n'est pas bonne
la situation électorale de la gauche
n'est pas bonne l'image du président de
la république n'est pas bonne
en revanche l'image de michel rocard a
d'excellentes alors comment est ce que
vous expliquez disons au moins ce
contraste
je n'ai jusqu'à présent jamais commenter
les sondages me concernant c'est un
exercice de commentateurs je suis acteur
et non commentateurs chacun son métier
si vous permettez une seule idée
peut-être vous devriez trouver viendriez
trop insistants sans cela peut-être
j'avais passé j'avais beaucoup parlé
avant juste avant 80 et beaucoup dit que
la crise était profonde qu'il fallait
prendre son temps pour la traiter qu'on
ne pouvait pas prétendre fournir des
avantages sociaux massifs avant d'avoir
construit les conditions de production
qui les financent et ainsi de suite
bonne raison pour me taire ensuite mes
bonnes raisons pour rester sur ce que
j'avais dît si vous le voulez bien
autrement dit c'est votre votre rigueur
et votre clairvoyance antérieures qui
ont tant donné votre module arrêté
actuelle la science économique ça existe
je n'avais pas à m'en faire des données
étaient là et j'aurais préféré qu'on les
oublie moins dans la préparation de
l'échéance vous vous sentez mieux je
dire qu'en ce qui concerne la politique
économique menée par le gouvernement
vous vous sentez mieux maintenant que il
ya deux ans maintenant que la balance
des paiements se redresse et que
l'inflation et la moitié de ce qu'elle
était il ya cinq ans un peu fini et est
maintenant que la politique menée par le
gouvernement est différente de ce
qu'elle était ce que vous avez mieux au
fond la politique économique depuis
1982-83 que celles qui étaient précédent
assurément dans les débuts du septennat
les choses ont couru trop vite et mais
on ne plaisante pas avec une balance des
paiements l'indépendance d'une nation se
mesure pour exclusivement dieu merci
mais assez largement à sa balance des
paiements nous avons maintenant repris
les choses en main et en effet pour ma
part je préfère que la balance des
paiements le taux d'inflation soit tenue
l'équilibré budget total
la limitation du déséquilibre budgétaire
aussi encore que ce ne soit qu'un moyen
ça les finalités sais c'est que la
monnaie soit stable et que la balance
des paiements soit équilibré nous ne
sommes que dans l'économique et dans le
financier ici mais que je voudrais
saisir cette occasion de dire que nous
sommes précisément au moment où la
potion fait mal aux malades avant qu'ils
se sentent en voie de guérison et seltz
une bonne partie pour tous mais une
bonne partie de la difficulté politique
du
tout ça alors ça m'amène justement la
question que je voulais vous poser le
rapport des forces est telle que les
spécialistes l'évaluent en ce moment
entre la gauche et la droite est de 40
est ce que vous croyez que la gauche
peut quand même gagner dans à peine plus
d'un an maintenant et surtout si oui à
quelles conditions peut-elle gagner
qu'est ce qu'elle doit faire
je me bats donc je ne discute pas
l'hypothèse d'une défaite si vous
permettez
il y encore pas loin de 18 mois avant
que nous ne voyons apparaître les
résultats positifs et notamment la
possibilité de d'attaquer le chômage
plus puissamment que nous faisons
maintenant donc de commencer à le
ralentir sinon à le faire baisser
les grands équilibres financiers dans
assainies et c'est tout ce que j'espère
mais le fond de l'affairé davantage une
affaire de dynamique et d'espoir que
seulement une affaire de technique
financière et vous croyez que ça peut se
réveiller dans les quinze mois qui
viennent et si oui comment je veux dire
parce que le gouvernement il fait des
efforts depuis qu'il est là sa manière
bien ou mal mais enfin il fait des
efforts je crois beaucoup tient à la
façon d'expliquer de rendre compte des
raisons pour lesquelles peut-être nous
avons au début du septennat fait un
certain nombre d'erreurs et voudront
longer d'ailleurs des erreurs
précédentes
et vous trouvez que maintenant on
explique bien disons que je me sens je
sens qu'il ya des assureurs progrès à
cet égard je crois tout le monde le
reconnaît dès hier sur le plan
économique et financier toujours qui
n'est pas la totalité de l'action
politique d'un gouvernement loin sens
alors bon le parti socialiste avait un
partenaire qui était le parti communiste
il n'a plus partenaires puisque parti
comme il s'est dit lui-même que
désormais il se situer en dehors de la
majorité
si comme vous le souhaitez vous le dis
car c'est d'ailleurs normal de votre
point de vue c'est comme vous le
souhaitez la gauche gagne dans un an
elle peut continuer comme ça un
gouverner sous forme minoritaire ou avec
d'autres
comment est ce que vous voyez les choses
le parti communiste est maître de ses
choix et de sa stratégie c'est à lui de
prendre la décision de préférer une
victoire de la droite à une victoire de
la gauche cela le regarde il rendra
compte à l'électorat c'est son affaire
il reste
nous avons au scrutin majoritaire à deux
tours et qu'il faut bien se rassembler
pour le second et que cela peut
permettre on l'a vu dans d'autres
circonstances tout de même une victoire
mais je pense surtout que le fond de la
sphère n'est pas là le fond d'affaires
c'est la clarté de l'objectif pour tous
les français alors justement vous
souhaitez qui loge un accord à peu près
6 programmatiquement tout cas une
plateforme avec les communistes ou pas
que vous mettiez d'accord sur un
ensemble de direction d'action de
propositions où on en est plus dans
l'ordre du discours
je souhaite que l'action gouvernementale
prennent et cela commence cela doit être
renforcée peut être infléchie isula
suffisamment de force
d'abord pour enregistrer des résultats
la politique n'est pas qu'une affaire de
discours et que cela soit suffisamment
convaincant pour entraîner ensuite y
compris le parti communiste français
pourquoi alors j'ai reçu plusieurs
lettres sur à propos d'une question
d'ailleurs j'aurais peut-être eu l'idée
de vous poser tout seul mais enfin j'ai
reçu plusieurs lettres là dessus mais
mes correspondants vais me disais en
1981 michel rocard voulait être candidat
à la présidence de la république
il avait dit que si françois mitterrand
l'été qu'il s'effacerait il s'est effacé
ce que j'allais dire il s'est effacé
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un d'autre que
françois mitterrand devant qui vous vous
effacez riez alain duhamel est une
question sérieuse ya un temps pour tout
j'ai commencé par dire tout à l'heure
que la politique n'était pas un
spectacle et que je n'étais pas venu
pour faire des gosses ou c'est pas du
tout venir dakhla ce que je crains dans
la france d'aujourd'hui est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai accepté cher de virer
votre invitation
c'est la montée des intolérances c'est
le fait que l'incapacité de s'écouter
les uns les autres
rendre toute action gouvernementale
presque impossibles ou très paralysé qui
que ce soit qui l'exercent
et quel que soit le vainqueur des
prochaines élections et je me bats pour
que la difficulté des problèmes soient
reconnus pour que les choses soit
reconnue complexe et qu'on s'entende les
uns les autres dans ce pays
par ailleurs les arraisonner liant tout
le monde si possible le vrai problème
sans majeur des politiques
or majorité politique le vrai problème
c'est que le débat politique est dominée
par des esprits rigide voire fanatique
alors que 80% des français ils répondent
bien à travers les sondages y compris
dans le
des intérêts de la politique partisane
manifeste qu'ils ont l'esprit souple
ouvert et qui servait de l'indre la
comprennent allusion à qui mes yeux pour
que le débat politique se dominer par
des esprits à la tonalité générale des
discours officiels d'apparition tros
mais bon ça bien carnation record de ça
et y compris mais l'autre si je veux
dire vous voulez vous amuser c'est
facile b d'accord là-dessus mais je veux
finir de répondre à votre question à la
pompe défilé je ne l'oublient pas et par
rapport à cela les campagnes électorales
et c'est une malédiction pour la
démocratie sont les pires des périodes
la cacophonie et un pointe atteint un
point tel que pendant les périodes
électorales
en général on n'entend plus parler du
fond des problèmes alors si vous le
voulez bien raccourcis sont les ne
vendez pas d'ouvrir aujourd'hui et à des
questions comme celles que vous me posez
je répondrais le temps venu et sûrement
pas avant et sûrement pas avant sûrement
pas avant que le temps soit venu mais
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est normal
que pour l'échéance qui est l'échéance
principale échéance présidentielle c'est
l'échéance rennes en france
est ce que est ce que vous trouvez ça on
ne sait pas parce que les l'alléchante
peuvent un peu se bousculent et s'est
passé a assuré que le président de
république est en très bonne santé
bah oui j'espère bien enfin ce père ya
pas que ça il ya aussi des accidents
politique bon on ne sait pas ce que sera
exactement calendrier alors est ce que
vous trouvez qu'il est normal que pour
cette échéance là ce soit comme ça se
fait à gauche est notamment parti
socialiste les militants et puis souvent
un peu plus que les militants presque
les professionnels de la politique qui
détermine qui doit être le candidat du
parti plutôt que comme ça se fait dans
d'autres pays les électeurs qui a envie
de voter pour un candidat
autrement dit est-ce que vous trouvez
normal que pour savoir qui doit être le
candidat du parti socialiste il faille
que ce soit une question d'appareils et
non pas des lecteurs ça ne me dites pas
que c'est la politique politicienne ça
n'en est pas c'est la sociologie
politique bat autres employés au rock
pop et dance est de vous plaire vous
posez une question très difficile parce
que vous mettez le doigt sur ce que les
français n'aiment pas même pas leur
parti politique et puis et puis on les
comprend je pourrais d'ailleurs eu les
comprenez fera ajouté oui je le
comprends un peu comme horizon pour ça
il reste que dans un pays moderne et
parce que modern compliqué on ne
gouverne pas censée organiser et il faut
entre les gouvernants et les gouvernés
une double relation descendante
pour que les décisions passées soit
appliquée alors là tout le monde fait
pareil le modèle est unique
cent soixante dix nations à l'onu font
la même chose s'appelle l'administration
on connaît bien mais il faut une liaison
ascendante
il faut collecter des confiances
rassembler des enthousiastes désigner
des candidats se battent pour leur
élection puis pour leur maintien en
place et où s'il ya candidature sinon il
faut accorder sa confiance au moins même
un dictateur a besoin de la confiance de
sa police et cette confiance montante
faut bien qu'elle se traduise quelque
part il ya quatre manières de faire
marcher la machine de l'état
les armes et les tribus en iran une
église et les partis politiques
il y en a pas d'autre c'est pas très
sympathique
les parties sont les sociétés où se
rassemblent toutes les ambitions
on n'y peut rien c'est comme ça je veux
dire ce soir que en effet la vie
intérieure des partis politiques portent
malaise puisque elle est la canalisation
d'eau mission et par conséquent cette
vie est dure mais je veux dire fermement
qu entre les tribus les armes et vous
l'église au pouvoir je ne vais entendre
parler de rien de tout cela
par conséquent il n'y a pas le choix
vous avez dit tout à l'heure est ce
normal
c'est dans la totalité des pays de la
planète vous avez fait une allusion
subtile au fait que dans pas tout à fait
la moitié des états des états unis
amérique
les électeurs votent dans des
conventions assez solide qu'à connus qui
ne recouvrent même pas la totalité mais
ça marche ça marche à moitié les
machines continue à faire le travail
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en effet
nous avons besoin de moderniser nos
partis politiques
nous avons besoin de les assouplir ne
croyez pas ne croyez pas que l'immunité
en politique soit complètement écartée
de la population les socialistes ont
aussi des voisins de palier des
camarades de travail des cousins avec
lesquels il faut bien qu'ils
s'expliquent
ils sont ce qui se passe aussi mais je
voudrais attirer l'attention sur autre
chose pour se grouper autour d'idées il
faut les formules et on les appelle
liberté démocratie on peut aussi les
appeler classe ouvrière
andres public a failli des mots dans
tous les sens et ses mots qui façonnent
les rassemblements il évolue moins vite
que les idées et la gauche qui a moins
de relations avec le monde de
l'entreprise moindre relation avec les
actes quotidiens du monde économique est
plus soudé à ses idées et par conséquent
souffre de les voir évoluer moins vite
mais j'ai été un briseur de rêve et j'ai
été un briseur d'idées aux cris de
faites attention ça ne sera pas si
facile de là tout se comprend y compris
mes petits malheurs et la raison pour
lesquelles ils sont en voie de
diminution film vous avez fait vos
quatre distinctions je veux pas revenir
dessus mais en france même
et bien que c'est qu'en france même il
ya deux techniques et à la technique dix
ans a pris fin de la droite dans lequel
quelqu'un dit je suis candidat puis se
tourner vers les partis en disant vous
me soutenez oui ou non
et puis les partis de gauche en tout cas
le parti sis dans lequel on lève la main
en disant monsieur ce que je peux être
candidat et puis on fait voter les
militants etc
ça vous paraît la seule technique
possible celle là je n'ai pas dit ça la
technique de la brutalisation et du fait
accompli n'est pas tout à fait civilisé
l'effort de civilisation qu'est la
délibération collective de ceux qui
dépensent leur temps leur argent leur
énergie pour cette cause mérite autant
de respect mérite autant de respect s'il
vous plaît même si les conditions dans
lesquelles se déroule actuellement une
certaine critique de l'opinion je me
bats moi même dans mon parti pour le
rendre toujours plus transparent et plus
démocrates avec de faibles succès au
départ mais probablement des chances
croissantes
vous venez de dire à l'un d'eux venait
de dire à l'instant que vous avez été à
un moment un briseur de rêves est ce qu
est ce que ça n'est pas le contraire
est ce que le rocardisme ce n'est pas
justement un rêve est ce qu'au fond ce
n'est pas la seule chose qui ne soit pas
appliquée en france est-ce que ça n'est
pas ça la raison de votre popularité
parce qu'après tout comme on n'a jamais
essayé on peut pas savoir jamais essayé
vous parlera tout à l'heure j'espère
d'agriculture je suis actif dans un
secteur jamais essayé s'il vous plaît on
n'en est plus là
oui bon je sais pas vous quitte
déterminer le sens de la politique
gouvernementale
ce que j'ai tenté d'illustrer avant de
me contenter de faire mon métier dans le
cadre d'une solidarité ministère et
silencieuse c'était un certain style de
comportement politique qui comportait le
respect des faits l'idée que l'état ne
doit pas tout faire
je suis un précurseur dans cette affaire
l'idée que les relations entre les
hommes et les femmes les relations de
groupe les relations économiques ne
doivent pas trop dépendre de la
réglementation mais l'idée surtout qu'on
devait respecter les contraintes les
faits ne pas se leurrer j'ai tout de
même longuement expliqué à mes dépends à
mes camarades socialistes que les choses
seraient plus difficiles que beaucoup ne
le croyait appelez cela comme vous
voudrez ces salles rocardisme oui je ne
sais pas si c'est un rêve je vous laisse
ce soin du commentaire bon monsieur le
ministre nous allons maintenant à les
asvp jean-louis sn d'autres questions
oui trois questions rapides monsieur le
ministre une aux leaders politiques une
au maire de conflans et une au ministre
de l'agriculture l'a posé deux
séparément jean-louis première question
pensez vous que des erreurs irréparables
ont été faites par la gauche depuis 81
et si oui lesquelles irréparable nom le
plus grave a été la sous-estimation de
la crise mais cette erreur nous est
commune avec nos prédécesseurs et par
conséquent il faut gérer les prenez la
sidérurgie il faut gérer les conditions
de problèmes traités trop tard et est
pas souvent très bien du premier coup
dans la continuité mais je ne pense pas
qu'il y en ait d'irréparable ça tu avais
peut-être avant de repasser la parole à
un super vous avez dit tout à l'heure en
répondant à duhamel qu' il fallait
attaquer le chômage plus puissamment que
nous ne faisons actuellement devrait
alors quand là je crois vraiment là
c'est une question qui intéresse
beaucoup les français ça veut dire quoi
attaquer le chômage plus puissamment 7
s'avise service qui est simple et vous
proposez quoi
c'est une question qui nécessite un tout
petit peu d'explications à vizille ou à
lisier nous revenons svp après la france
vit beaucoup de drames à la fois qui
inquiète tous ses habitants sécurité à
venir des enfants
immigration chômage comment est-ce que
tout cela se tient
nous sommes une vieille terre
d'immigration depuis très longtemps et
jamais on s'était posé de problème sur
le fait de digérer des communautés
nouvelles
maintenant il ya de l'inquiétude
pourquoi à cause de la montée de la
délinquance
pourquoi la délinquance monde tels en
fait tout le monde le sait bien et même
les sondages d'opinion répondre dans ce
sens c'est d'abord le chômage avant tout
autre phénomène
c'est donc le chômage qu'il faut
attaquer comme variables principales
or nous sommes coincés par une espèce de
verrous dramatique
la france achète à l'étranger 25 % de
tout ce qu'elle consomme et si nous
voulons avoir une croissance qui est la
vraie solution au chômage
eh bien nous achèterons aux autres plus
vite plus plus que nous leur vendons ce
qui est la limitation centrale
alors je crois que le fond de la réponse
à la question c'est profiter de la
situation notre balance des paiements
est en train de stationner là notre
inflation en train de diminuer pour
maintenir cet effort
si on se relâchèrent quoi que ce soit
les plus grosses difficultés
reviendra-t-il immédiatement mais il
faut faire maintenant l'offensive pour
créer tous les emplois possibles et ça
compte nombreuses dizaines de milliers
peut-être une ou deux centaines de
milliers là où le travail de ces emplois
peut directement améliorer notre balance
des paiements je pense aux économies
d'énergie je pense à au développement
nos services d'exportation à l'étranger
je pense à quantité de choses de ce
genre
prenons l'exemple des économies
d'énergie monsieur le président de la
république est venu à conflans sainte
honorine voir sur place les résultats
d'un énorme effort que nous avions faits
qui donnait de très très bons résultats
de ses résultats un mort qui pour les
extrapoler au niveau national on ira
passivité pas si fort je peux dire que
la mobilisation un grand emprunt
anti-chômage pourquoi pas d'une
vingtaine à une trentaine de milliards
de francs
exclusivement centrée sur la maîtrise de
l'énergie peut probablement provoquer
une bonne centaine de milliers d'emplois
nouveaux sinon davantage dans cette
branche et en même temps nous faire
économiser plus de 1000 dizaines de
milliards de francs par an par an en
balance des paiements ces emplois là ils
sont créateurs d'un meilleur équilibre
de valence
qu'est-ce qui s'y opposent une vision un
peu trop notarial de la gestion de nos
finances publiques mais nous sommes très
observé que celle des gens qui occupent
la fonction actuellement mais toute la
semaine pour en rire mais s'il nous faut
mais j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il
fallait infléchir cette politique j'ai
une seconde idée qu'on s'est aperçu que
le francs d'impôts le mieux utilisé par
l'êta lefranc d'impôts payés par les
français est celui qu'on met dans le
financement des services d des services
commerciaux de nos entreprises à
l'étranger pour 1 franc milla en général
on a deux francs rentrées en devises
l'année suivante
multiplions c'était fort là et trouvant
des économies au ferrailleur encore une
autre idée puisque vous y tenez je
voudrais dire aussi qu une des
difficultés que nous avons tient à la
manière dont nous finançons notre
système de garantie sociale la france a
un système de garantie sociale qui est
un des meilleurs du monde tout le monde
a entendu parler de la sécu et la sécu
on la finance par des cotisations sur
les salaires
il se trouve que nous faisons ça dans
des conditions très dissuasif de
l'emploi et je pense pour ma part que si
la même masse de cotisations sociales ou
les appliquer sur 90% des effectifs et
pour sur la totalité y aurait plus de
gains en charge sociale si vérone les
patrons licenciait une limitation et
surtout les nouveaux embauchés on les
embauche récents charges sociales le
temps qu'ils rentrent dans la moyenne
des effectifs sur trois ans cette
souplesse
en voilà une nous permettrait de créer
probable en quelques dizaines milliers
dans ce qu'avait j'en vois cela qui est
orfèvre tout à l'heure vous posant cette
question manquait d'abord pour la
nazairienne de vous mais bon ben on va
d'abord revenir
on va d'abord dire
svp une autre question j'ai joué
monsieur le ministre allait beaucoup de
téléspectateurs souhaiterait maintenant
parce que vous avez dit passer de la
théorie à la pratique que conseil de
nivelles traduire le tout petit mais
dans la pratique doit être même trop cas
particulier que quand ils vous faire
concrètement dans le conflit elle tettey
qui se trouve dans votre circonscription
pour éviter les licenciements
oui je crois qu'il faut rappeler qu'elle
tt thompson c'est la téléphonie c'est la
distribution cédé répéteurs les
décodeurs et aussi la fameuse fibre
optique là et qu'il ya des licenciements
importants prévus ltt venir lignes
télégraphiques de téléphonie qui est une
filiale du groupe thomson actuellement
gérées par la cge et dont une usine est
implantée à conflans sainte honorine
c'est vrai elle avait 4000 travailleurs
quand j'ai été élu maire en 1977 elle en
a 16 cents en ce moment et après une
compression d'effectifs de 400 au
printemps dernier et on parle d'une
nouvelle réduction d'effectifs de 2 500
ou 600 personnes de rien du tout si vous
permettez moi ce n'est pas le ministre
en charge qui parle je n'ai pas la
responsabilité de ce dossier ce que je
fais c'est donc que je me bats je
considère que la mutation de notre
industrie que les changements sociaux
doivent être faits en prenant en
considération les difficultés
il n'est pas admissible après tout ce
que cette entreprise avec dans le niveau
de désespérance de ceux qui restent et
de toute la ville autour d'eux que l'on
continue dans cette fois il s'agit d'une
filiale d'un grand groupe
il y a des commandes parti dans ce
groupe des remembrements sont possibles
je le sais je n'ai pas l'habitude de
demander qu'on fasse n'importe quoi mais
là je dis le traitement de ce problème
n'a pas été correctement conduit jusqu'à
présent et je n'admets pas pour ma part
que l'on parle de licenciement comme ça
sexe en d'examiner d'abord un plan de
redressement industriel de l'entreprise
et ensuite les conséquences sociales de
ce plan de redressement industriel
c'est une exigence général par rapport à
tous ceux qui ont dossier en charge il
faut dire que cette entreprise
malheureuse a changé cinq fois de
direction générale depuis sept ans
qu'elle a été ballottée d'un groupe à
l'autre jusqu'à ce qu'enfin la
nationalisation met un peu de clarté
durabilité dans la gestion mais nous
n'avons pas encore la chance de voir les
conséquences précises passé sur le
terrain
mais c'était ça le capitalisme vous
rendez compte une entreprise
vendus ont perdu profit cinq fois tu
trois fois de suite en quatre ou cinq
ans alors naturellement il ne s'y passe
et plus rien ne faisait plus de
recherche c'est un drame affreux mais la
société
et le gouvernement la responsabilité de
préserver cet outil industriel
bon nous reviendrons asvp tout à l'heure
mais tout de suite j'en vois cela j'en
vois cela rédacteur en chef de
l'expansion
je vais essayer de combler votre voeu
est de venir au secours de votre
modestie vous êtes trop bon vous l'avez
dit vous aviez beaucoup chanté et
maintenant vous danser depuis 1980
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne juge plus sur ce
que vous dites mais sur ce que vous
faites
je ne vais pas vous faire porter la
responsabilité de tout ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement bien que vous en soyez
solidaires observons ce qui vous a
concerné vous directement
d'abord ministre du plan puis ministre
de l'agriculture ministre du plan vous
avez eu en charge d'abord le plan
intérimaire
l'élément essentiel du plan intérimaire
j'ai pris la précaution de leur lit la
priorité des priorités
c'était la lutte pour l'emploi il était
prévu que sur deux années 1982 et 1983
pour retourner la tendance en matière de
chômage en france l'économie française
créerait net
quatre cent mille à cinq cent mille
emplois chiffre inscrit dans le plan
chiffres réalisés n'ont pas création
nette de 4 à 500 mille emplois mais
destruction nette de 110 mille emplois
pendant la même période
comment vous commentez l'échec du plan
intérimaire c'est à dire du document que
vous aviez en charge et dont vous aviez
la responsabilité plusieurs choses la
première est que dans l'ensemble des
moyens de réaliser ce pronostic j'avais
dès ce moment-là demandé que soit
immédiatement affecté 30 milliards de
francs de l'époque de l'époque aux
économies d'énergie nous revoilà un
point que nous évoquions à l'instant et
ses moyens bon ne se sont pas trouvés la
trentenaire l'époque ça doit en faire
plus de 40 d'aujourd'hui et c'était
probablement dû pas loin de 200 mille
emplois qui était en cause et qui
intéressait directement la balance des
paiements
deuxième élément nous avions tous tous
les experts et toutes les forces
politiques fait à peu près la même
erreur
nous avions sous-estimé à quel point
notre appareil productif était peu
capable de faire rapidement face à une
augmentation interne de la consommation
et les importations se sont développées
beaucoup plus vite que tout le monde ne
l'avait pensé prévu que les modèles de
disette
c'est en effet une erreur elle a été
largement partagée mais ministre du plan
gelé pour ma part largement assumé
le troisième élément est lié à l'or à
l'environnement autour de nous la hausse
du dollar ne nous a pas fait que du bien
pendant toute cette période
vous connaissez tous ses élans dollars
ça vous permet de vendre à l'étranger
ah oui mais ça renchérit d'abord la
facture pétrolière le temps ça renchérit
d'abord les importations avant qu'on
commence à gagner à l'exportation parce
que là il faut voir investie développer
les services commerciaux il faut du
temps s'était fait retard vous en a même
parlé dans beaucoup de vos articles vous
le connaissez bien même et les autres
pays on tirait profit la hausse du
dollar
les autres pays avaient commencé
l'assainissement financier de leur
économie bien avant nous n'oublions pas
que l'assainissement américain il a été
fait en 78 79 l'assainissement allemand
vers 80 avant la date à laquelle le
président mitterrand était élu tout de
même si vous permettez ce rappel n'a
rien de polémiquer purement de
calendrier donc première et chaque le
plan intérimaire
ensuite vous avez fait adopter le
dernier plan cinq ans est un élément
essentiel de la planification ce qui
correspondait d'ailleurs à ce que vous
aviez toujours dit c'était une
planification de type contractuels et en
particulier des contrats entre l'état et
les régions
vous avez apporté beaucoup de soin l'un
d'entre eux a été signés notamment avec
la région alsace et il prévoyait
signature de l'état l'installation d'un
synchrotron à strasbourg d'un seul coup
quelqu'un qui n'était pas membre du
gouvernement mais qui était député d'une
autre région
l'isère monsieur mermaz annoncé que ne
serait pas à strasbourg mais que ce
serait à grenoble les alsaciens ont été
furieux
quid du concept qui vous tient beaucoup
à coeur de planification contractuels
lorsque au premier à la première
occasion
l'état renie sa signature jeu et
répondre à cela mais je voudrais d'abord
rappeler que le deuxième plan ne
concernait pas et de loin que cet aspect
du moins qu'à mon désir il n'aurait pas
dû se limiter à cet aspect des contrats
de plan et je ne vois pas pourquoi je ne
dirai pas ce soir la souffrance que j'ai
eue de voir la notion même de plans mis
en cause par des socialistes
voilà comme je le pense et cela vaut
aussi en partie pour le plan intérimaire
il reste qu'en effet du 9e plan le
morceau le plus puissant plus solides ce
sont les contrats de plan parce que je
crois que là nous avons g j'ai créé une
mécanique d'adhésion qui peut permettre
la conjonction de l'effort de l'effort
de réflexion des ford actions
administratives mais surtout de l'effort
financier de l'état et des échelons
régionaux ou service des mêmes objectifs
de faire de la décentralisation une
convergence des efforts plutôt que de
prendre le risque d'une trop grande
diversification
je crois beaucoup à cette procédure il
m'est arrivé d'en dire avec quelque
fierté que je pensais qu'elle
transformerait les mentalités
collectives de la gestion économique de
la france en trois ou quatre plans en 20
ans nous avons neuf siècles de
centralisation derrière nous sinon
davantage si on la fait remonter non
philippe le bel savait moins de neuf
siècles tout de même mais c'était
beaucoup de siècle le royaume impériaux
des républicains de centralisation sont
des mentalités qu'il faut transformer
alors vous concevez qu'effectivement
cette affaire du synchrotron m'a fait
très mal
il n'est pas approuvé la lorientaise je
crois qu'il faut la comprendre et pour
autant que j'ai bien compris ce qui
s'est passé la décision a été prise sans
que les responsables de cette décision
et eu connaissance de l'engagement
contractuel est écrit de l'état
et ça ça doit nous mener à réfléchir
très très loin excusez moi je voudrais
finir ce qu'on appelle l'état c'était
grave mais justement ce qu'on appelle
l'état
quand ça s'engage j'ai dans l'esprit qui
ça fait près d'une dizaine de milliers
de décideurs
il ya bien sûr un président de la
république un premier ministre une
quarantaine de ministres beaucoup de
parlementaires députés sénateurs par un
européen
tous nos préfets tous nos commissaire
divisionnaire de police tous nos
ambassadeurs tous les chefs d'entreprise
nationaliser tous les directeurs
d'offices publics tous les directeurs
d'administration centrale
tous les directeurs départementaux tout
un ensemble de gens qui au jour le jour
font leur métier discrètement ou les
entend peu on entend que les sommes et
puis vient un problème un coup dur 1
drame sanitaire ou d'accident ou de
violence ou de n'importe où quelque part
un commissaire de police un préfet un
ambassadeur se trouvent en situation il
peut avoir le mot de trop l'état c'est
tout ça les contrats de plan ça a été
une négociation extrêmement complexe il
ya 15 cents projets repéré ce que j'ai
considéré comme un très grand succès
pour cette idée à laquelle je suis très
attaché c'est toutes les régions de
france sauf la corse qui au moment en
cause n'avaient plus d'assemblée mais
elle va y venir
il est presque prêt toutes les régions
de france majorité et opposition non
signé et je suis convaincu que cette
grande mécanique fera changer beaucoup
de choses il se trouve qu'elle comporte
des quantités de dispositions et qu'en
effet il faut organiser la machine de
l'état
ce nombre prodigieux de décideurs avec
une communication absolument permanente
de l'information c'est difficile c'est
très difficile on l'a vu sur le tchad on
l'a vu sur des quantités de choses là
l'absolu cohérence ou concordance de
l'information pour prendre les décisions
de l'information nécessaire pour en
parler ou les commenter entre les
quelques centaines de personnes qui sont
l'état sur un problème déterminer allez
on ne gouverne pas sans bavure c'est là
est grave mais tout le monde fait des
bavures un des drames de notre époque
c'est peut-être que notre exigence de
démocratie et l'instantanéité de nos
communications nous fait donner trop de
poids l'événement instantanée par
rapport à la distance et du coup la
bavure dans l'actuelle gouverner avec
tous les temps de toutes les époques on
gouverne pas sans bavure encore une fois
la bavure dans l'acte de nîmes de
gouverner devient l'enjeu essentiel du
commentaire politique il ya de quoi
fragiliser bien des démocraties
ouais mais plus on donne du piment au
jeu électoral on est sûr de sortir et
certains chaque coup puisque tout le
temps des bavures
non mais plus risquées parce que ça
qu'on fait des choses sérieuses plaies
en zoulou préconisé on planifie plus en
risque les bavures explique
puis on planifie plus en risque l ai
bavé ça n'est pas cr à haut risque des
bavures si on planifie une mère trop
rigide or ce n'était pas l'esprit mais
précisément ce gars là est venue il ya
bavure mais écoutez après un siècle de
centralisation nourault dont pour la
première fois pour la première fois
l'idée que l'état au lieu d'être
régaliens comme on dit impérial de
s'engager tout seul de ne jamais
négocier avec personne vous savez par
exemple qu'un accord que l'état négocie
avec ses propres fonctionnaires est
réputé il égale devant la loi
l'état n'a pas le droit de négocier
notre droit c'est l'état impérial nous
avons donc violé l'esprit de ce droit
français pour lancer des contre-attaqués
en effet qu'il n'est pas encore tout à
fait rodez nous n'avons pas encore
mesuré la sécurité de transmission
d'informations et tous les échelons
dissidents pour des attentions
un engagement est pris il sera tenu je
vais même vous dire autre chose en bois
sauvage nous prendrait probablement pas
parce que je vous sais très bien
informée les contrats de plan pour
l'essentiel au contraire et conditions
dans lesquelles ils sont respectés pour
leur parti budgétaires sont une de leurs
forces
nous apprenons cette mécanique d'état
donc vous conseille vous admettez un
échec qu au moins sur un point
j'aime mes décisions dont troisième
exemple vous êtes ministre de
l'agriculture en tant que tel où
siégeaient dans les conseils de
bruxelles
et vous avez vu des décisions difficiles
à prendre avec vos collègues
concernant la politique agricole commune
oh certes vous aviez parlé tout à
l'heure de votre voeu d'une économie
même animé par une majorité de gauche ou
le marché la non bureaucratisation la
non intervention de l'état dans la vie
économique quotidienne était souhaitable
or vous êtes le ministre l'agriculture
en france en accord avec vos collègues
européens qui avaient décidé de
réglementer la production des tiers en
europe
autrement dit dans ce domaine précis ce
n'est pas plus d'autonomie que vous
donnez
aux entreprises mais moins d'autonomie
puisque vous devez réglementée vous avez
envoyé des papiers qui doivent être
remplies dans des laiteries pour décider
ce que l'on va diminuer ici ou ailleurs
quid de ceux qui viendront après ceux
qui auront accepté de diminuer leur
production et cetera autrement dit vous
faites de l'économique administrer le
contraire de ce que vous nous avez
expliqué au début de ton de cette
émission le contraire dieu merci
j'espère pour ce seul secteur
en effet j'ai même dit plus que cela et
vous êtes gentils de votre commentaire
moi j'ai donné un nom de baptême à ça
nous avons rationné le droit à produire
pourquoi parce qu'on est même permis il
faut être sérieux et responsable c'est
en 1974 ou 75 que la production laitière
de la communauté économique européenne a
commencé à dépasser ses capacités
d'absorption tentant consommation
intérieure quand une exportation a
commencé avant non l'équilibré on arrive
on a passé il ya eu il ya eu des crises
avant mais conjoncturel savez la météo
et eu des crises conjoncturelles mais
structurellement c'est aux environs
1974-75 que la production laitière est
devenu durablement excédentaires par
rapport à nos possibilités
or la production là que politique
agricole commune étaient fondées en
matière laitière sur ce principe d'appui
aux producteurs mais à condition que ce
soit conjoncturelle que quand les choses
à faire aller mal on stockait non pas le
lait c'est peu stockables mais le beurre
ou la poudre de lait pour leur vendre
après et éviter que leurs revenus ne
s'effondre troupe danse est devenue
structurelle on y est on a plus et nous
sommes tombés devant la rareté de
l'argent on pouvait plus payer
tu vois ce nas et pas où vous apprendrez
que quand il y à une rareté
il faut y faire face en temps de guerre
c'est plutôt la rareté des biens
physiques là c'était la rareté de
l'argent et tout le monde sait et
notamment dans le monde paysan qu'il ait
une limite à ce qu'on peut faire payer
par le contribuable
les collectifs les quand j'ai été nommé
ministre j'ai pris connaissance de ce
dossier
l'agriculture et je me suis aperçu qu'au
fond il y avait un accord implicite un
peu par l'acheter chez beaucoup de
gouvernements européens pour laisser les
choses aller à vau l'eau jusqu'au moment
ne paierait plus et puis on dirait
terminé la politique agricole plus
d'argent des boyaux et je voyais fort
bien que si les ministres de
l'agriculture n'avait pas pris leurs
responsabilités
on serait arrivé simplement
l'effondrement des prix des biens par
l'arrêt de l'intervention s'était tout
et je prétend qu en amputant qu en
plafonnant le droit de produire et pour
la france à 3% de en dessous du niveau
de 1983 2 % la première année 1 % la
seconde importe peu nous avons sauvé
l'essentiel de cette politique
il avait la gangrène nous on fait de la
chirurgie du genre suis intervenue
suffisamment à temps pour pouvoir ne
couper que quelques phalanges deux ou
trois ans après j'ai eu beaucoup de
conseils de laisser filer il ya une
certain type de discours de l'opposition
j'ai dit ça où tu es aussi d'un autre
soir qui m'amènerait à dire qu'après
tout j'aurais pu leur laisser le bébé
pour 1986 et là au lieu des phalanges
voudrait couper le bras mais debout sur
d'avoir laissé filer vous avez déclaré à
l'issue d'une session du conseil des
ministres
un autre conseil des ministres européens
qui a traité du problème du budget
européen
vous avez déclaré que les décisions qui
avaient été prises là était une
imbécillité collective
mais si je me mets ce soir à la place de
votre collègue pierre bérégovoy que vous
avez gentiment qualifié de notaire tout
à l'air et que vous aviez encore plus
aimablement s'il vous plaît à je
regrette tout le monde l'a entendu le
vrai par la gestion au thorium de la
gestion notariale séoul derrière pearson
dans l'administration française des
finances aux 36 bits et vos miettes à
noter qu'un imbécile parce que vous
l'avez me suis fait une imbécillité
collective en voyage vous en prie ah non
moi je ce sont vos propos et parler mes
propos ne s'appliquait pas un homme
il s'applique à une philosophie une
pratique administrative réticente à une
colis piégé a pris feu n'avait pas le
droit d'en tellement maintenant un
ministre du gouvernement
vous êtes mans et j'ai parlé de
pratiques administratives d'habitude en
effet notariale
administration des finances elles sont
très anciennes je les connais bien j'en
suis de cette administration
et croyez moi j'en suis un critique
interne forte efficace je vous interdis
je trouve ça scandaleux avant de faire
jeunesse les personnes avait parlé d'
imbécillité collective
oui ou non attendez on est sur la
seconde map pierre bérégovoy tout à
l'heure à propos de notariale je veux
dire ici que le courage d'un ministre
peut parfois a consisté justement a
réveillé une administration et c'est ce
que j'espère qu'il est en train de faire
j'ai confiance
il ya une lourdeur administrative que
vous avez suffisamment incriminés dans
divers papiers pour que je sois sûr
d'avoir votre accord intellectuelle là
dessus vous ne m'aidez mentirai pas
quant au problème de l'imbécillité
collective alors là je maintiens
absolument mais c'est pas pour lui mais
saison qui sait pour les neuf autres et
si vous voulez qu'on dise des noms sont
pas le gie ce n'est contre c'est pour le
chancelier de l'échiquier britannique et
pour le ministre allemand des finances
non et que cela va leur faire très
plaisir ville et négation apport mais
s'ils étaient contre vous vous souvenez
du déroulement de la faire non mais s'il
était contre c'est tout ce que je
demande
reprenons si vous voulez bien la
conduite de l'ensemble du gouvernement
français à laquelle lui aussi a donné
son accord bien on évoque l'année
dernière la nécessité de ralentir la
dépense agricoles ce qui est vrai nous
commençons à nous en charger
sérieusement nous ministre de
l'agriculture en ralentissant la vitesse
de dépenses notamment dans l'est ça fait
mal c'était inévitable et je regrette
qu'il n'y ait pas eu d'autres formules
que le rationnement si on s'était pris
10 en avant 74 75 encore une fois on
aurait pu éviter rationnement c'est un
autre problème
vient ensuite à la suite de
délibérations dont je ne connais pas
bien l'origine la transformation de
cette idée discipline budgétaire en un
monstrueux carcan qui venu dans son état
le pire un premier conseil à faire
mme économique et financier se voit
opposer la réserve de la france déposée
par qui par pierre bérégovoy au sortir
de là et sachant qu'il avait déposé la
réserve du gouvernement français je
donne l'explication vu du côté de
l'agriculture de ce que un carcan
suffisait pas deux nous avions déjà les
quotas laitiers
nous sommes en train d'aggraver
l'obligation distillerie obligatoirement
du vin pour réduire les excédents et ça
n'est pas une chose facile
ils sont sans doute encore à cette heure
ci à dublin nos chefs d'état et de
gouvernement entend discuter du vin pour
la même raison
mais il était ultra dangereux d'aggraver
la chose en mettant une interdiction de
dépenser le ce qui doit continuer à être
dépensé pour le président trouve son
équilibre mais ça c'est à venir
l'imbécillité que c'était juste avant
nous allons ensuite dans la bataille
suivante avec une position du
gouvernement français parfaitement
ajustée d'un commun accord entre roland
dumas pierre bergoin moi même les trois
négociateurs et vérifier en séance vous
en aurez les témoignages que vous
voudrez de demi heure et demie heure
parce que nous n'étions pas dans une
même salle les petits papiers passait
hier bérégovoy amiens soin jaloux à
vérifier que j'étais d'accord avec tel
ou tel élément pourquoi nous étions dans
une seringue
un possible grâce à la réserve de la
semaine d'avant transformé en coup
d'éclat par ce que j'en avais dit nous
avions soulager le champ et améliorer
beaucoup les positions vers lesquels on
était en train de culminer nous étions
tombés d'accord eshet est tombé d'accord
parce que figurez-vous que l'imbécillité
collectif gelé contre signé aussi donc
si vous prenez les choses comme ça pour
faire de la politique politicienne fois
en 11 s et par moi je suis en hérésie
mais j'ai pas parlé d' imbéciles
revenant sur la question on change
d'époque tout à fait finie je dis
simplement que la france n'avait plus le
droit de ne pas de bloquer la mécanique
et qu'il fallait rien arriver à quelque
chose que quelque chose a été moins
terrible mais par ma bouche le
gouvernement français commentant ce qui
s'était fait dit que ce carcan ne
tiendra pas et que c'est déjà
suffisamment difficile on le voit au
conseil agricole d'économiser de la
dépense agricole pour qu on nous rajoute
pas un carcan qui tombe n'importe
comment
dernière est ce que ça voulait demander
à pierre bérégovoy en anglais en demi
heure nous avons joué d'accord je
retiens que cet accord a été acquis avec
la participation des ministres français
yvon bello mienne est compris la puissa
n'empêche pas de le juger celui là
mauvais accord très bien ça fait
beaucoup de mauvaises choses en peu de
temps et
je termine un contre eux disent vous
savez là l'ami kane ont alors été au les
autres s'en servent la france et noise
et tous les autres sincère quand on
régresse anglais pour 2% production
c'est 6% en belgique c'est 7% en
allemagne fédérale ces 6 7 8 % aux
pays-bas
ça sert le droit de ces dernières
questions puisque je ne veux pas abuser
du temps le président de la république
vient de réaffirmer que l'objectif du
socialisme en france est la rupture avec
le capitalisme est ce votre sentiment
confucius a écrit quelque part
et encore je voyais philippe le bel si
je gouverne est je resterai le sens des
mots je commencerai par rétablir le sens
des mots quand le président de la
république a dit cette phrase il voulait
rappeler à ses électeurs et ou plus
intense plus actifs de ses électeurs
pour le mans les militants des
organisations de gauche qu'il se
souvient de ce sur quoi il a été élu
mais nous voilà avec ce mot devant une
affaire assez tragique où la manière
dont il est employé par ceux qui ont mis
des dizaines d'années et serment au 19e
siècle à façonner leurs émotions leur
accord leur enthousiasme leur
organisation collective autour la
manière dont ils l'emploi maintenant
n'est plus comprise par personne d'autre
il ya toujours des difficultés entre
patrons et vous voyez même dans les
nationaliser on en a vu beaucoup de
confiance et honorine
mais il paraît qu'il faut pas appeler ça
comme ça alors peu importe parlons de
conflits sociaux
souvenons qu'ils sont tout de même le
moteur de l'histoire et et rappelons
nous qu on ne peut pas dans une
démocratie faire comme s'il n'existait
pas que souvent la manière de les
traiter de leur chercher des solutions
négociées et pacifique plutôt que de
laisser la situation pourrir et devenir
violente et le signe de la bonne santé
d'une démocratie
cela implique qu'un pouvoir quels qu'ils
soient mais surtout un pouvoir de gauche
n'oublie pas les engagements des coûte
les engagements aussi de procédure qu'il
a pris à cet égard je ne crois pas que
messi il m'importe peu moi je ne crois
pas que le président va public penser à
davantage en tout cas là c'est bon
d'interprétation et c'est ma manière à
moi
voir les choses mais on ne peut plus
parler de rien j'aimerais rétablir le
sens des bons ajustements est ce que
vous vous êtes favorable à la rupture
avec le capitalisme comme but du
socialiste français le capitalisme a mis
deux siècles et demi a remplacé la
féodalité et ça a été une longue
bataille menée par des chefs
d'entreprises des banquiers des
bourgeois je ne sais pas si il avait un
goût des mots aussi forts que le nôtre
pour décrire ce qui faisait et je ne
suis pas sûr qu'une fois que vraiment
les derniers germes de féodalité et
disparus et une assemblée sonel pour
dire ça y est on a rompu avec les
féodalités jeu c'est d'ailleurs encore
tel département de france l'un par
exemple où la tenure des terres est
encore un peu ce qu'elle était avant
bon on apprend tout à fait fini qu'est
ce que c'est que le capitalisme c'est
une ex un extraordinaire système
d'organisation sociale qui a su utiliser
avec une immense souplesse toute la
technicité industriel mécanique du monde
moderne et où la liberté de chaque chef
d'entreprise a donné au système un
dynamisme qu'on avait jamais vu dans
l'histoire ça s'est traduit par beaucoup
de sauvagerie le développement est
extrêmement brutal on l'a oublié chez
nous n'oublions pas le temps les 70
heures de travail par semaine sans autre
fait carillonner que les dimanches sans
arrêt ni pause d'été et jusqu'à la mort
travailler jusqu'à sa mort regardons
presque tout le tiers-monde dans
l'incapacité de trouver son
développement avec cette technique là à
travers cela tous les hommes pour qui le
mot socialisme signifie l'espoir et dieu
sait que ça veut dire d'être choses bien
différentes
tous les hommes pour qu'ils montent
social ici ni fils espoirs voudrait se
battre contre c'est injuste
les socialistes allemands n'ont jamais
dit qu'ils voulaient rompre aussi l'on
dit pendant cinquante ans de leur
histoire mais une année à grande finale
18 depuis 20 ans ils ont compris eux
peut-être plus vite que nous que la
vraie rupture c'est celle qui consiste à
refuser dans l'organisation d'une
économie compétitive l'arbitraire du
pouvoir économique et cette rupture là
pourquoi ne pas vous faire sourire je
crois d'abord qu'elle passe beaucoup par
la négociation sociale qu'elle dépend
peu des des affaires suprême au niveau
de l'état
et je sais même ici ou là ou tel chef
d'entreprise qu'il entreprend
vigoureusement par la compréhension
qu'il a du problème mais si vous voulez
dramatiser le mot faire de la rupture du
capitalisme une affaire de violences de
rue je n'ai rien ses parents qui en
parle c'est changer d'échelle pas pour
wii il avoue ne pas pouvoir c'est ce que
nous retiendrons alors nous retournons
maintenant asvp jean-louis lesaint
d'autres questions mais peut-être avant
avant que jean lui scène je crois que
pour la vérité historique faut quand
même rappeler que c'est quand même pas
la surproduction laitière n'a pas
commencé en 1975 qui a eu un plan d'aval
d'abattage des vaches et européennes dès
1969 qu'on s'est rendu compte ensuite
quand il était allé trop loin dans la
lutte contre la surproduction sur
l'histoire que je connais l'histoire y
est vous aviez des phase conjoncturelle
pour lisser les moyennes fait baisser
les effets du breton dans le revêtement
est agriculteur qui ont abattu leurs
vaches à cette époque-là considère que
le lissage des moyennes non je regarde
sans les lieux et éthiquement devenu
structurellement il ya paix
raison de plus si on avait fait 169 on
serait pas au total et on l'a fait on
l'a fait on est allé trop loin
alors svp d'autres questions oui
justement sur ce thème monsieur le
ministre une question concernant notre
secteur l'agriculture en ethiopie mais
aussi en france des gens ou fin
comment accepter l'abattage de vaches à
cause de la surproduction mais comment
pouvez-vous justifier le gaspillage que
représente la destruction d'excédents
agricoles
le problème est de mon coeur de dieu
actuellement avec la distillation du vin
notamment à bas prix je ne dirais pas
que ces destructions
d'excédent d'être justifiée et moi
socialiste je peux dire que c'est
moralement que tout cela me choque que
tout soit bien montre bien le caractère
au fond inadmissible de l'organisation
du monde mais il se trouve que le marché
à ses excès qu'il faut bien les
compenser nous utilisons une part
croissante de ses excédents à répondre
la pauvreté en france même mon ministère
en ce moment mettent en place des
systèmes de distribution de 5 grands
produits blé à usage de pain viande
pommes pommes de terre et les et pour
faire face aux situations des plus
démunis d'entre les habitants de notre
pays et notamment de ceux qui sont
chômeurs en fin de droits pour le
tiers-monde aussi le volume des aides
alimentaires va lentement croissant mais
il ne faut pas croire que les choses
sont simples et il faut savoir par
exemple qu'à une population qui vit 2002
millet de patates douces et de sorgho
qui a tellement faim qu'elle a quitté
ses villages pour essayer de s'approcher
vers des camps dans la ville qui n'a
plus les moyens de faire du feu et qui
n'a plus de quoi broyer le blé si vous
lui apportez du blé ne sera pas quoi en
faire
apporter de la poudre de lait s'est fait
à l'hypothèse qu'il ya là-bas de l'eau
potable non microbienne et de toute
façon tout cela on sait que en ethiopie
par exemple les deux tiers des gens qui
sont menacés de mourir de faim seront
installés vivent à 3 ou 4 mai à 30 ou 40
km au moins de tout route et on n'a pas
assez de camions pour transporter
autrement dit toutes ces choses sont
extraordinairement difficile
l'aide alimentaire nous la pousse on
nous sommes en train de faire des
efforts mais il faut savoir qu'on ne
résout rien quand on est seulement les
gens à survire momentanément et que le
problème de fond c'est le développement
de l'agriculture productive ivry hier du
tiers-monde c'est ça la vraie bataille
les règles cruel du jeu internationales
ont souvent provoqué des situations où
qui ont empêché le développement des
agricultures vivrières locales du tirman
nous avons trop pousser ces pays à faire
des cultures d'exportation pour chez
nous du lin du coton de l'arachide du
cacao du café donc ils n'ont rien venir
alimentaire chez eux et est comme ça on
les a beaucoup pas ce fichier surtout
cela il faut avoir le courage de revenir
et les y aider l'aide alimentaire n'est
qu'un palliatif nous le feu
en autant que nous pouvons et par
ailleurs il faut en effet organiser nos
marchés de manière à ne pas avoir ces
conditions scandaleuses dans lesquelles
en effet les producteurs faute de
débouchés ne trouve plus à gagner leur
vie normalement ce sont des questions
d'organisation de régulation et c'est
bien là on s'aperçoit qu'on ne peut pas
laisser faire n'importe quoi et quand ce
moment cette cristallisation de la
pensée collective autour du
désengagement général de l'état de ce
qu'on appelle le libéralisme est
extraordinairement dangereuse il faut
être plus simple plus intelligent sans
doute savoir mieux laisser jouer les
intérêts des producteurs directement
mais dans des règles du jeu plus
strictes et mieux définie et c'est cela
la grande condition de l'organisation de
l'économie pour seulement sur le champ
agricole votre question oui on en
revient à une des questions qui vous a
été posée au début de l'émission est il
exact que lors de la constitution du
gouvernement fabius
on vous a proposé le portefeuille de
l'éducation nationale est vous l'avez
refusé pourquoi est ce que vous craignez
un échec personnel
il est exact que j'ai refusé ce
portefeuille
si je craignais un échec personnel je
n'aurais peut-être pas que c'était celui
de l'agriculture devrait pas vous
laisser croire que c'était facile
non je pensais que ce qui était
commencée devait être continuée que je
n'étais pas l'homme le mieux placé pour
le faire
on avait vu refuser d'autres
portefeuilles me suffit d'avoir refusé
suis là et d'avoir accepté l'agriculture
vient pas d'autres questions pour
l'instant 6 9 radios libres sont saisis
actuellement à paris qu'en pensez vous
est ce que vous trouvez cela comme
normal
faudrait savoir pourquoi en ce qui
concerne les radios libres
le
gouvernement et le parlement depuis 1981
ont déjà beaucoup avancé
nous avons reconnu un certain nombre de
critères un certain nombre de radios un
accord semblait en voie de se faire sur
ces critères là aussi l'expérience
italienne par exemple montre qu'on ne
peut pas laisser faire absolument
n'importe quoi
les ondes ne doivent pas être une jungle
il ya une prolifération tel d'ailleurs
que sur certaines longueurs d'onde on ne
s'entend plus il faut aussi faire une
certaine police des ondes et c'est
peut-être ça qui est en cause derrière
je souhaite que l'on en arrive enfin un
assainissement de cette matière à une
compréhension mutuelle à une répartition
des longueurs d'onde
elles ne sont pas illimitées tout le
monde ne pourra pas être m c'est bien
clair et il faut simplement trouver des
règles du jeu mieux admise alors albert
du roy pour le dernier quart d'heure
cette émission dernier quart d'heure
avant que nous ne retournions svp albert
du roy sur un car est ce que je me
trompe si je tire la conclusion de votre
échange avec jean boissonnat que vous
vous n'auriez jamais parlé de rupture
avec le capitalisme comme l'a fait le
président de république
j'en ai beaucoup parlé avant 1980 pour
expliquer qu'à mon sens elle prendrait
plusieurs dizaines d'années et qu'elle
était une affaire de mentalité
nous sommes tous un peu propriétaire
nous sommes tous un peu attentifs à
l'argent est le vrai capitalisme est une
question de relation avec l'argent
donc vous l'avez dit mais vous ne diriez
plus et j'ai dit qu un autre système
social peut émerger et que ça mettra du
temps et si nous y travaillons est ce
que vous avez comme moi comme peut-être
d'autres beaucoup le sentiment depuis le
début de cette émission d'avoir été
d'une extraordinaire sévérité à l'égard
de la gauche au pouvoir
j'en suis je peux on essaiera qu'avec
ses amis mais mais je n'avais pas cette
impression mais n'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir été sévère pas trop j'ai dit ce
que je pensais ce que beaucoup de gens
savent que je pense même à propos
d'éducation nationale ça veut dire quoi
on est sévère qu'avec ses amis quand
vous dites je n'ai pas été sage qui
trompe attaché à tous l'espoir de plus
de justice de construction de l'avenir
dans ce pays de remise sur pied tout
notre système scolaire de résorption du
chômage je suis trop attaché à tout cela
pour effectivement m'accommoder de ce
que cet espoir soit un peu mise en cause
ici ou là par une faiblesse une action
mal placé ou n'osent pas fait à temps et
par conséquent cela me met en colère
c'est vrai alors au bout du système
scolaire justement dont on vient de
parler un instant
quand la gauche est elle la plus fidèle
avec elle-même quand elle voulait il ya
quelques mois une île unifier le système
d'enseignement et de laïciser ou caen
actuellement elle essaye de trouver un
moyen termes et des conditions de pour
faire vivre l'enseignement privé
la gauche n'est vraiment fidèle à elle
même que quand elle assure l'école un
grand projet rayonnant et quand elle se
refuse à tout sectarisme d'un grand
projet rayonnante
écrivez moi ce sont des mots qu'est ce
que cela recouvre ça recouvre que dans
ce débat les choses seraient peut-être
différente si l'école publique se
portait mieux pourquoi toute cette
importance à ce débat pour beaucoup de
raisons mais l'une d'entre elles est que
la crise de l'école publique
l'école de la république celle dont je
sors et tels que l'école privée apparaît
à bien des familles comme une sécurité
et vous n'étiez pas bien placé pour
redonner à l'enseignement public se
toute sa qualité toute sa valeur je
voudrais attirer votre attention d'abord
sur le fait que j'étais attaché au même
problème puisque j'ai eu à le traiter
sur le plan de l'agriculture et
qu'effectivement j'ai eu la cense 18
mois de négociations 14 version du texte
d'arriver là à traiter le problème des
rapports juridiques entre l'état et
l'enseignement agricole privé
vous auriez dans les régions de montrer
l'accord vous auriez pu réussir ça dans
le cadre de l'enseignement général
je n'en suis pas sûr reichen
pense pas que j'étais compte tenu des
conditions politiques dans lesquelles se
présenter le dossier l'homme le plus
qualifié pour le faire comme ce que vous
êtes resté ce que ça a pesé dans votre
décision de rester à l'agriculture
le fait d'arriver de conclure cet accord
qui était dans les tuyaux depuis 18 mois
pas seulement mais en partie oui j'avais
très envie de boucler ce dossier là il
ya d'autres problèmes sur lesquels je
souhaite en effet montré que la
politique suivie est efficace et aura de
bons résultats le vin notamment comme
vous parlez peu souvent on envie de vous
interroger sur énormément de questions
différentes alors je vais les igg
rennais elles n'ont pas de rapport l'une
avec l'autre elles sont très diverses et
elle s'adresse à l'homme politique parce
qu elle ne recouvre pas votre secteur
ministériel a beaucoup la nouvelle
calédonie qui est une préoccupation
actuelle des gens et du gouvernement
les deux mots d'ordre du gouvernement du
premier ministre c'est le dialogue et
l'ordre est ce qu'à votre sens il faut
d'abord restaurer l'ordre avant
d'entamer le dialogue ou est ce qu'il
faut faire les deux à la fois faut faire
les deux à la fois je ne suis pas se
salir céder à la pression non ne faisons
tout de même le pari de l'intelligence
et n'appelons pas céder à la pression le
fait de recommencer à se parler
faites attention commentateurs à votre
propre rôle vous êtes fabricant de mot
vous aussi les journalistes et il faut
bien réfléchir à cela
le mythe avec jamais un homme politique
ne doit se permettre de mettre en cause
le système médiatique etc en effet on le
paye toujours abominablement mais je
trouve là une image extrême quand ces
conditions dans les payant cette tribune
ayant des minimes aux est une question
posée peut très bien changer l'esprit
public sur la manière de prendre les
choses si dialoguer et cédé à la
pression si l'on admet ce raccourci
alors le dialogue devient impossible
dans un jugement moral qui résulterait
de notre dialogue en nouvelle calédonie
et ça c'est terrible
vous ne m'aidez nouvelle calédonie de
josé ne s'est pas finir il est
parfaitement clair qu on ne dialogue pas
dans le désordre et qu'il faut retrouver
le calme c'est à dire aussi l'ordre
je crois cependant que l'ordre est liée
au dialogue est ce que par exemple il
est envisageable pour le gouvernement
français gouvernement socialiste
d'organiser
tin d'autodétermination en nouvelle
calédonie scrutin au cours duquel une
partie de la population la population
d'origine européenne ne voterai pas cela
ne paraît pas envisageable et c'est
précisément toute la difficulté
monsieur giscard d'estaing lui-même
était partisan d'autodétermination en
1976 mais l'auto détermination de toute
façon ne peut être ne peut se dérouler
c'est le monde écrit qu'un choix ce
choix sera réel si diverses options
clairement définies sont offertes
l'une peut être l'indépendance et
l'autre peut-être le maintien dans le
cadre de la république française dans
des conditions institutionnelles à
définir ce qui me donne ne trouvent le
plus en ce moment sur la nouvelle
calédonie ce n'est même pas ce problème
là c'est le fait que ce que tout le
monde a dans la tête c'est à dire le mot
d'indépendance soit aujourd'hui l'objet
de malentendus et on parle de
l'indépendance dans deux sens il est
concevable que la nouvelle calédonie
trouve une indépendance et exerce cette
indépendance dans un fonctionnement
harmonieux d'une communauté multiraciale
ayant des institutions il ya d'autres
exemples dans le monde ça marche plus ou
moins bien souvent marcher dans des
institutions où chaque communauté
s'exprimer à sa place mais il est clair
qu'il y à une autre variante de
l'indépendance qui est la dépendance
pour la seule communauté kanak à
l'exclusion des autres communautés
présentes dans ce territoire
ça ce n'est pas possible c'est même
contraire aux droits de l'homme
c'est contraire à tout ce que disent la
plupart des mouvements d'indépendance
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que le
congrès national africain d'afrique du
sud
c'est noir persécutés pourchassés
emprisonnés et c'est dans leur congrès
clandestins reconnaissent la citoyenneté
des banques d'afrique du sud
il faut le savoir qu'en namibie où
l'indépendance est conquise après de
dures rutte
ce sont deux communautés qui travaille
mon collègue namibien est un blanc
pardon en si de bach oui j'ai confondu
la namibie elle cherche son indépendance
je viens de confondre avec le zimbabwe
et cette attitude des mouvements
d'indépendance sont plus respectable que
l'attitude des kanaks là ils doivent
comprendre que qu'il n'y a pas de
dialogue possible en effet s'ils
prétendent à l'indépendance pour l'heure
seules communautés en prétendant rejeté
les autres à la mer ici ou là on a des
déclarations visent non non on veut pas
les rejeter à la mer
il faut que les choses soient appréciées
que les caldoches et des garanties
puisque qu'elle dauchy c'est bien clair
d'une façon plus générale est ce que
dans ces matières où le terrorisme
intervient on peut pas la nouvelle
calédonie mais aussi de la corse mais
aussi du pays basque est ce que l'état
fait se fait suffisamment respectés on
peut dès l'instant qu'il y a un malaise
social quelque part et que ce malaise se
traduit par des violences
dire que l'état ne se fait pas assez
respecté et on peut souhaiter qu'ils se
fassent plus respectés il est cependant
vrai que ce sont les conditions
historiques économiques sociales qui
crée une situation le cas de nouvelle
calédonie est très précaire sous l a été
traiter indigènes à statut de
l'indigénat cetera dans les conditions
d'un colonialisme passé outrancier
jusqu'en 1945 les mélanésiens sont
devenus citoyens français en 1945 et
grâce d'ailleurs la constitution 47 même
pas tous des 45 si ma mémoire est tout à
fait exact
une somme public à la nouvelle calédonie
là nous sommes dans un cas les gens je
vous réponds sur le respect de l'état
dans la nouvelle calédonie en nouvelle
calédonie
la loi cadre de 1956 à créer un statut
du territoire qui lui a donné son
autonomie dans la république française
un ministre des gouvernements les deux
communautés s'entendait bien
elles étaient toutes les deux
représenter le respect de l'état était
assuré avec peu de forces de police pour
des raisons très dommageable et et pas
très respectable historiquement en 1963
la vème république mais a mis fin aux
garanties du territoire à son statut et
la ramaz au statut de territoire
d'outre-mer sans même les structures
représentatives d'un de nos départements
et c'est là que les choses ont commencé
à se crisper assez greer et qu'on n'a
plus jamais plus rien rattraper voilà
comment les choses se sont passées nous
payons 1963 que l'état se fasse
respecter dans ces conditions supposées
à la fois une recherche une saisine
dialogue attend ça n'a pas été fait nous
l'avons tenté depuis 1980 nous arrivions
bien tard et aussi une montée
considérable de forces de police mais
jusqu'à quel niveau prénom vous savez
fort bien que dans ces engrenages
il ya un moment où l'art de se faire
respecter ton à la répression ou la
répression des clans justement le cycle
infernal justement prenons prenons un
autre exemple qui va tout à fait dans ce
sens là il ya quelques mois on a extradé
des terroristes basques en la première
fois ça même créé des rumeurs et de la
grogne à gauche
est-ce que vous en avez pensé je n'ai
pas été heureux car effectivement la
manière dont ses hommes se sont conduits
à des prétextes politiques mais il
s'agissait tout de même de meurtre de
complicité de meurtre nous avions jusque
là refusé absolument toute extradition
parce que l'espagne était une dictature
fasciste qu'on y sortirait et qu'on y
tuer dans ces prisons que les droits de
l'homme n'étaient pas garanties devant
ces tribunaux ling démocratie mais alors
pourquoi et c'est devenu une démocratie
est bien mais parce que maintenant nous
avons avec elle des relations normales
de démocratie et donc sans quoi cette
mesure vous ne vous at-elle pas rendu
heureux
cette extradition vous l'avez dit ça ne
m'a pas été pas heureux il est fréquent
quelque part ça vous gêne
bien sûr mais je crois tout de même
qu'il n'y avait pas de choix nous
n'avions pas le droit de ne pas
considérer l'espagne comme étant devenu
une démocratie respectable et cela en
effet est un changement il est
vraisemblable que les juges espagnols
seront sévères avec ses hommes pour voir
comment ils se conduisent mais c'est
leur responsabilité nous avons nous une
double certitude
la première c'est que la justice
espagnole maintenant répond à un pays où
les droits de l'homme sont le principe
constitutionnel et la seconde c'est que
on peut voter en espagne que
l'indépendantisme basque se présente aux
élections il y fait une minorité et par
conséquent qu'il s'agit d'actes de
terrorisme pour faire changer par la
violence lavez la situation d'un peuple
qui majoritairement n'a pas reconnu
cette orientation comme la sienne vous
étiez d'accord on les traditions ou pas
d'accord ou l'extrader c'est donc été
d'accord pour l'extradition d'accord
mais je ne vous dis pas qu'on en est
heureusement et facilement d'accord
naturellement j'étais d'accord
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
sentiment d'insécurité en france est
excessif
actuellement est ce que vous avez
l'impression que actuellement le
gouvernement
préoccupe plus trop du maintien de
l'ordre et de la lutte contre la
délinquance et plus assez de justice il
faut coller de choses venir et elle pas
ensemble on ne se préoccupe jamais assez
de la sécurité des français surtout s'il
se sent inquiet il est vrai que leur
perception de leur inquiétude dépasse
peut-être la réalité il est vrai par
exemple c'est une chose peu connu que
les sentences moyenne rendues par les
juridictions françaises sont les plus
sévères d'europe
il est vrai aussi par exemple qu'il n'y
a pas eu depuis 1981 de mise en
permission de détenus inculpés pour
cause de meurtres de policiers
contrairement à ce qui a été dit il est
vrai encore qu'avec un policier ou un
gendarme pour 262 habitants
la france bat le record d'europe alors
où en est on il ya eu l'an dernier un
sondage fait sur l'insécurité dans le
métro et on a eu la surprise de
découvrir que 7% des de la population
représentative des voyageurs du métro
disent avoir été personnellement victime
d'une agression cela aurait donné 150
mille agressions dans le métro l'an
dernier ah oui on a eu 15 285 6 mois ma
mémoire est exact elles ne sont pas
toutes déclaré je sais disons qu'il ya
pu y en avoir dix mille je dire loin
puisqu'on a eu 15 185 de repérer mais
cent cinquante mille personnes ont vécu
ce qu'elle regardait de loin ou se sont
imaginé ou se sont dit que répondent
comme cela pire vous incriminez mais à
rente deux incriminés les meilleurs
incrimine rien je regarde j'essaye de
comprendre et s'il ya un problème sur
lequel il est nécessaire que les
français se comprennent
c'est bien celui là pour ne pas
dramatiser je continue avec le même
sondage il est fascinant 42 % des
voyageurs du métro répondent qu'ils ont
assisté ou connaissent quelqu'un qui a
été victime d'une agression
ça donnerait 900000 agressions dans le
métro l'an dernier donc vous avez un
vécu de l'agression bien au delà de ce
qu'elle est et si cela qu'il faut faire
comprendre aux français tout en traitant
sérieusement les problèmes nous avons
embauché plus de 15000 personnel de
police policiers et gendarmes depuis
1981 c'est un triplement de la vitesse
de recrutement de ces forces par rapport
à ce qui se passait avant encore une
fois nos sentence judiciaire sont parmi
les plus fortes d'europe
nous savons et le garde des sceaux c'est
le premier que le grand problème le plus
grand à cet égard et celui de la
rapidité des décisions de justice
un détail ce n'est significatif le fait
que dans toutes ses statistiques de
délits les contraventions de
stationnement et les chèques sans
provision faut toujours compter qu'ils
sont des dizaines de milliers qui vont
faire tous les chiffres partout on a vu
par exemple que la ville de
saint-etienne voir sa délinquance
progressé de 39% et on s'est aperçus
après c'était parce que
un organisme spécialisé dans le coma une
grande surface enfin déposés là ces
plaintes juridictionnelle pour chèques
sans provision pour toute la france
alors plus entre 9% et voilà tous les
stéphanois inquiet voilà donc de quoi il
faut se débarrasser
sortons tout cela et puis sachant aussi
que ça prend du temps la magistrature et
que les efforts très rapides que nous
faisons pour automatiser ses procédures
et ses décisions pour nous permettre de
gagner du temps mon avis gilbert
bonnemaison qui préside la commission de
sécurité qui est une commission où se
réunissent des maires de grandes villes
majorité et opposition
c'est lui informatiser son commissariat
de police ce qui pour la dépense de
salaire d'un agent en une année lui a
permis de remettre trois agents en
service dans la rue depuis le taux
d'élucidation des délits a doublé donc
il y a des quantités de choses à faire
et nous les faisons mais je crois
d'abord il faut avoir la lucidité de
regarder les problèmes de face la
sécurité croît lentement
elle n'est pas à des niveaux dramatique
nous nous battons contre elle et nous le
ferons d'autant mieux que chacun se
comprendre ce qui monte ce qui est
vraiment dangereux c'est la petite
délinquance c'est à dire ce qui est lié
au chômage et ça nous ramène à mon
propos de tout à l'heure c'est en se
servant des possibilités d'emploi avec
lesquels nous économiserions de la
balance des paiements on pourra créer
des emplois commencé à détendre puisque
c'est l'emploi qui crée c'est le chômage
qui crée la délinquance et la
délinquance qui crée l'intolérance à
l'immigration
tout le problème français se ficelles
comme ça voilà l'ordre dans lequel il
faut si vous êtes
l'homme le plus populaire des sondages
comme le rappelait tout à l'heure l'un
des plus impopulaires c'est robert
badinter remise de la justice que pensez
vous de cette situation qu'il ya là une
grande injustice et c'est pourquoi je
suis heureux qu'il ait accepté mon
invitation d'être avec nous ce soir je
change tout à fait de sujet on parle on
commence à parler de la réforme
électorale le parti socialiste est très
divisée entre le scrutin majoritaire du
scrutin proportionnel l'efficacité et la
justice
je voudrais connaître votre avis
question il n'ya pas de scrutin parfait
il faut que ce scrutin soit efficace
c'est une de ces conditions tout aussi
impérative que de celle de le voir
plutôt juste je crois moi que la france
est un pays suffisamment porté à
l'intolérance et au fanatisme mutuelle
là pour être difficile à gouverner et
que dans ces conditions il faut d'abord
exiger un scrutin qui fournissent des
majorités dont il y en a beaucoup de
sens lorsque tu es majoritaire oui c'est
clair on peut le matinée d'un peu de
proportionnelle à la marge si l'on a le
souci d'une représentativité plus large
de certaines fractions l'électorat alors
été votre avis mais même quand vous
étiez au psu comme étant une petite
minorité qui n'avait de chances de
figurer que si c'était un scrutin
proportionnel sur ce point
déjà il m'était arrivé d'être
minoritaire dans la gauche mais rassurez
vous ça diminue et je suis de plus en
plus majoritaires peut-être même sur ce
point là on verra bien ça c'est moins
sûr on a beaucoup on a beaucoup parlé de
la gauche dans cette émission on a très
peu parlé de l'opposition actuelle de la
droite des centristes
est ce que dans leur attitude vous voyez
des motifs voyez certainement des motifs
d'inquiétude
est ce que vous voyez des motifs aussi
d'espoir sur par exemple une
décrispation du débat politique
est-ce que vous appréciez le
rajeunissement par exemple des
responsables des partis d'opposition est
ce que parmi ces jeunes vous trouver une
autre façon de se comporter à l'égard de
la vie politique
écoutez la jeunesse est une affaire
d'état d'esprit
c'est souvent un moyen une aide mais
mais ce ne sont même pas par tranche
d'âge que se joue la vie politique
française tout de même je voudrais
saluer justement sur le problème de la
sécurité dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure le courage de quelques hommes de
l'opposition comme beaucoup de la
majorité mais quelques zones de
l'opposition qui ont dit des choses
comme n'accusons pas le gouvernement de
tous les assassinats de vieilles dames
restons rigoureux etc
mais je voudrais dire aussi depuis
quelques semaines une croissante
consternation chef que comment comment
éviter d'être trop méchant nous en avons
beaucoup parlé au début de cette
émission j'avais souffert avant le mai
1981 de ce que la gauche faisait parfois
des promesses que je ne trouvais pas
très raisonnable et que je savais
difficile à tenir et avait une pratique
de l'opposition qu'il n'était pas très
sensible au sens de l'état il m'est
arrivé de me demander si en moins trois
ans et demi de départ du gouvernement
notre position n'était pas pour certains
de ses membres et certaines de ses
forces devenu aussi bête que nous ne
l'avions été en 25 ans d'absence du
gouvernent goûté on travaille au rpr sur
la défense et on sort cette grande idée
qu'il faut faire passer le budget de la
défense de 4 à 5% du produit national
brut dames les messieurs les
téléspectateurs ces 82 milliards de
francs nouveau qu'il faudrait mettre
dans la défense ou les prendre personne
ne sait alors bien sûr on c'est corrigé
on a changé les affaires mais c'est
intéressant c'est comme le synchrotron
sur qui commande et comment marche le
système de décision là dedans or
contandin par l'appareil de l'état sur
le dos ça devrait tout de même un peu
plus facile
prenez ce problème de cohabitation le
changement a vu entrant semaine de
monsieur chirac a de quoi inquiéter tous
ses supporters
où est-ce qu'ils vont aller s'il est
d'abord ultra pourrait ensuite ultra
compte
tout ça n'est pas très très raisonnable
vraiment j'ai été inquiet je pensais
cependant que l'expérience du pouvoir du
rpt est assez longtemps pour que dans la
conscience commune de la difficulté des
responsabilités la france trouve enfin
un art de dialoguer ensemble et je
voudrais dire plus que cela je voudrais
dire que je vis intensément quelque
chose que je crois très important
la france est une démocratie un peu
imparfaite parce que l'alternance y joue
mal et l'alternance y joue mal parce que
la gauche affaibli dans ses performances
gouvernementales notamment dans l'ordre
économique monétaire et financier et
voilà que obligé à la durée par les
institutions la moitié gauche de
l'opinion publique française s'explique
avec la réalité d'une balance des
paiements de la gestion monétaire
commencent à prendre en charge tous ces
problèmes en sibérie contraintes
assainir effectivement les situations
dans la modernisation industrielle nous
allons au fond des choses davantage que
nos prédécesseurs
je suis sans pitié par exemple pour le
dossier de la sidérurgie et ça c'est
plutôt monsieur bart qui est en cause
enfin nous n'entrons pas dans le détail
je pense que cela doit continuer je
pense je le pense d'autant plus que nous
n'avons pas eu le temps ce soir du tout
d'aborder la scène internationale et je
le regrette
le grand allié américain dont nous
devons être les alliés indéfectibles
dans ce monde de tension et de danger
qu'ils représentent une terre de liberté
chez eux sont malgré tout en train sur
la scène internationale de jouer un jeu
d'un égoïsme dangereux ils veulent
asphyxier la banque mondiale le fonds
monétaire international
récemment la banque agricole mondiale
qui s'appelle le fida on annonce même le
retrait du gatt pour ne plus traiter
qu'avec leurs clients il faut que
l'europe d'une voix libres leur parle
fermement et à cet égard une france
indépendante et je crois la gauche mieux
doué pour mener ce combat là le
continuer le fasse il faut que nous
renforcions notre solidarité européenne
autour d'une monnaie c'est maintenant
possible les qu émerge et il faut que
les efforts qu'on commençait souhaite
engager avec ce que j'observe de notre
position sur laquelle vous m'interrogez
le citoyen que je suis pourrait se dire
bien nous ne réussissons
qu'imparfaitement la france est une
démocratie ses hommes ont montré qu'ils
étaient capables
on pourrait de loin se dire après tout
pourquoi pas je ne dis plus ils me font
peur tant d'irresponsabilité un retour
aux pires défauts de l'opposition aussi
vite c'est tout de même un peu désolant
dernière petite question devrait savoir
ce que pense
l'ancien étudiant socialiste l'ancien
manifestants de rue y compris dans les
manifestations violentes lorsque devenu
ministre il est dans sa voiture de
fonction protégés par des escouades de
policiers en moto et parfois par des crs
qui le protège contre des manifestants
c'est parce que vous pensez à ces
moments là
eh bien je pense que c'est une évolution
normale dans la vie qu'il est des causes
que je reconnais parfois juste dans ce
que j'entends que nous gérons les
tensions d'une société et que je préfère
les gérer dans mon pays qui est une
belle démocratie que n'importe où
ailleurs un retour as v p jean-louis le
scène oui deux questions pour terminer
monsieur rocard la première sur votre
parti d'origine ps eu visiblement
certains téléspectateurs se sont rendus
compte qu'il y avait une âme bouchardeau
derrière vous qu'y at il de commun ou de
différends entre le michel rocard du ps
eut et celui du ps c'est plus une
question pour les commentateurs que pour
moi même j'espère avoir montré qui a
beaucoup de commun sait depuis longtemps
que le souci d'une gauche d'un
socialisme qui se soucient pas seulement
de redistribuer la richesse mais de la
produire m'anime
et cela je n'ai pas changé d'avis depuis
le ps juge avait déjà tenu ce discours à
mes camarades
mais un autre point commun est tout à
fait fondamental c'est l'idée qu'une
société ne vit pas seulement des actes
de son gouvernement et que la france
après tant de siècles de centralisation
a besoin d'une pratique sociale de se
retrouver elle même auto laissions ça
voulait dire cela et c'est la part qui
est juste dans cette recherche d'un
désengagement de l'état que je vois trop
vite cristallisé dans ce mot trop
général de libéralisme sous lequel il ya
le meilleur la liberté depuis le pire la
loi de la jungle en matière économique
par rapport à cela une société qui ne
laisse pas tout faire à l'état qui se
débarrasse de la bureaucratie c'est une
société qui négocie avec elle même le
fait qu'aujourd'hui la négociation
sociale soit au point bas est un des
dangers pour la france je suis toujours
un militant de la négociation sociale de
la pratique sociale de l'innovation
sociale et aussi comme mais on pourrait
en parler
il ya beaucoup de continuité savez-vous
un moindre goût peut-être pour
l'expression prophétique et un plus
grand souci de la faire passer dans les
faits
mais ça c'est le lot de toute histoire
personnelle et paie une dernière
question oui de réflexion qui se
rejoignent une plutôt gentille d'un
employé de marseille
j'ai 36 ans dit il ma génération a
manqué le rendez vous avec mendès france
va-t-on manqué le rendez vous avec
rocard est une autre question un peu
plus méchante
ne craignez-vous pas de devenir le
poulidor de la gauche d'abord poulidor
tout de même il ne faut pas sourire mais
disons que quand je crois une pause je
veux pas pour elle et que je ne sais pas
raisonner en terme de défaite la france
a encore un immense avenir devant elle
nous sommes dans ce continent européen
qui sent un peu la décadence où on ne
renouvelle plus notre population
mais la france est celui des pays
d'europe qui est le moins inférieur au
taux de renouvellement démographique la
france et celui des pays d'europe qui
possède les plus grandes des chances
industrielle de l'avenir dans le spatial
dans l'exploration des fonds sous marins
dans ces industries biotechnologiques
dont je parlais au début qu'elle vienne
de la chimie du blé ou de sel du sucre
ou dans d'autres dans certains créneaux
de l'électronique la france et puissante
elle peut l'être qu'elle par le haut et
fort qu'elle n'oublie ni sa langue ni
ses amis
j'ai une petite pensée au passage pour
le liban n'ont pas parlé d' affaires
internationales et c'est dommage que la
france n'oublie pas tout ce qu'elle
porte elle a un avenir à se faire la
seule crainte que j'ai c'est que nous
sombrions dans nos fanatisme et nos
intolérances
il y faut des responsables politiques
qui sache se battent et qui croit à
quelque chose
je suis de ceux-là la france a le choix
c'est aussi de ses richesses la
comparaison avec ma d'esserent souplesse
et le monarque est rentable merci
c'était donc l'heure de vérité de michel
rocard merci prochain rendez vous le
lundi 7 janvier
[Musique]